nous ont permis d'obtenir des résultats
incontestables
nous étions parvenus au cours de ces
dernières semaines
inédit nous ont permis d'obtenir les
résultats incontestables
nous étions parvenus au cours de ces
dernières semaines à passer sous les
2000 contamination par jour contre près
de 35 millions au plus haut de la crise
les hospitalisations comme les décès
sont aux abois depuis près d'un an en
vous disant tout cela je pense
évidemment aux victimes et à leurs
proches
la vie malgré tout a pu continuer durant
ces mois difficiles parce que nous nous
sommes organisés collectivement si nous
avons demandé beaucoup aux enseignants
parents d'élèves qui ont dû s'adapter
dans l'urgence quand soudain une classe
fermée si nous avons nous demandé
beaucoup aussi à nos élèves et nos
étudiants
la france a largement préservés
l'instruction durant cette crise
douze semaines de fermeture pour nos
écoles depuis mars 2020 alors qu'aux
états unis les écoles ont fermé durant
cinquante six semaines ou en allemagne
durant 34 semaines certains cours ont pu
reprendre physiquement à l'université
ces derniers mois nous pouvons être
fiers de cela de ce choix collectif de
la nation d'avoir fait le maximum pour
l'avenir de nos enfants et d'autre de
notre jeunesse
cet été comme à la rentrée nous
accentuerons encore nos efforts pour
apporter un soutien renforcé aux élèves
et aux us
étudiants qui rencontrent des
difficultés sur le plan économique le
quoi qu'il en coûte auquel je m'étais
engagé dès mars 2020 non seulement nous
a permis de protéger nos entreprises nos
emplois mais à préserver le pouvoir
d'achat de nombre de français et est à
l'origine d'un vigoureux robot notre
croissance devrait s'établir à 1 6% en
2021 en tête des grandes économies
européennes la france pour la deuxième
année consécutive a été désigné comme le
pays le plus attractif d'europe
contrairement aux prévisions l'emploi a
résisté et les acquis obtenus depuis
2010 est en termes de baisse du solde du
chômage sont préservés en 2020
le coc vide a détruit près de 300000
emplois depuis le début de l'année nous
avons déjà re créé 187 milles emplois
ce seul mois de mai nous avons atteint
un nombre de contrats à durée
indéterminée créé inédit égalant notre
record de 2006 dans tous les secteurs
qui comme la culture l'hôtellerie la
restauration le sport le tourisme ont le
plus souffert
chacun reconnaît que les plans de
soutien spécifique que nous avons mises
en oeuvre ont permis d'empêcher les
drames humains les faillites et
d'envisager une reprise sereine nous
restons pleinement mobilisés pour aider
ceux qui ont subi la crise plus
fortement que d'autres
les salariés travaillant dans les
entreprises qui n'ont pas résisté
où les jeunes comme les indépendants qui
durant cette période sont
malheureusement tombés dans la pauvreté
je veux vous dire ce soir que nous avons
eu raison collectivement de rechercher
sans cesse l' équilibre entre la
protection et la liberté raison au début
de cette année de protéger la vie sans
pour autant refermer le pays cette
situation maîtrisée c'est le fruit de
nos choix de nos efforts ces choix et
nos résultats nous permettent d'aborder
les difficultés qui sont encore devant
nous avec détermination
car oui à l'heure où je vous parle
notre pays est confronté à une reprise
forte de l'épidémie qui touche tous les
territoires métropole comme outre-mer
aussi longtemps que le virus circulera
nous serons confrontés à ce type de
situation l'apparition du variant dit
delta se traduit en effet par une
augmentation des contaminations partout
dans le monde parce que ce variant est
trois fois plus contagieux que la
première souche il s'engouffre dans tous
les espaces non couverts par la
vaccination
pour y faire face de nouvelles mesures
de restriction ont été décidées aux pays
bas au portugal ou en espagne en asie et
dans le pacifique certains pays ont dû
se résoudre à un recond fumant et le
japon imaginez qu'ils s'apprêtent à
organiser les jeux olympiques le fera
sans autre qu'un spectateur
et si chez nous en france la situation
est pour le moment maîtrisé
si nous n'agissons pas dès aujourd'hui
le nombre de cas va continuer de monter
fortement et entraînera inévitablement
des hospitalisations en hausse dès le
mois d'août nous avons pour faire face à
cette nouvelle donne un atout maître qui
change tout par rapport aux vagues
précédentes le vaccin tous les vaccins
disponibles en france nous protège
solidement contre ce variant delta il
divise par 12 son pouvoir de
contamination est vite 95% des formes
graves
l'équation est simple plus nous
vaccinerons - nous laisserons d' espaces
au virus pour se diffuser plus nous
éviterons les hospitalisations et plus
nous éviterons d'autres mutations du
virus peut être plus dangereux encore
c'est donc une nouvelle course de
vitesse qui est engagée un été de
mobilisation pour la vaccination
voilà ce que nous devons viser vacciner
un maximum de personnes partout à tout
moment
nous sommes une grande nation une nation
de science celle des lumières de louis
pasteur
alors quand la science vous offre les
moyens de nous protéger nous devons les
utiliser avec confiance dans la raison
et dans le progrès pour nous protéger et
pour notre unité
nous devons aller vers la vaccination de
tous les français
car c'est le seul chemin vers l'euro
tours à la vie normale dans un premier
temps pour les personnels soignants et
non soignants des hôpitaux des cliniques
des maisons de retraite des
établissements pour personnes en
situation de handicap pour tous les
professionnels aux bénévoles qui
travaillent au contact des personnes
âgées ou fragiles y compris à domicile
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire
sans attendre j'ai conscience de ce que
je vous demande
je sais que vous êtes prêts à cet
engagement cela participe aux quelque
sorte de votre sens du devoir pour tous
nos compatriotes concernés ils auront
jusqu'au 15 septembre pour se faire
vacciner
il faut commencer dès maintenant à
partir du 15 septembre des contrôles
seront opérés et des sanctions seront
prises il ya ensuite tous les autres
françaises et français les millions
d'entre vous qui n'ont pour le moment
reçu aucune injection en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation nous devrons
sans doute nous poser la question de la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous les
français mais je fais le choix de la
confiance et j'appelle solennellement
tous nos concitoyens non vaccinés à
aller se faire vacciner dès aujourd'hui
au plus vite
9 millions de doses vous attendre dès
aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas encore été
injectés et nos commandes continuent
d'arriver
que ce soit donc près de chez vous sur
votre lieu de vacances avec ou sans
rendez vous faites vous vacciner
c'est la seule façon de vous protéger et
de protéger les autres
c'est une question de responsabilité
individuelle de sens de l'esprit
collectif
c'est aussi ce dont dépend notre liberté
à toutes et tous je pense en particulier
à tous nos concitoyens de plus de 60 ans
et aux personnes vulnérables dont celles
qui sont en surpoids grave qui ne sont
pas encore vaccinés aujourd'hui vous
êtes celles et ceux qui courent est
aujourd'hui le plus grand danger
j'en appelle donc à votre mobilisation
déploieront durant tout l'été la
vaccination au plus près du terrain en
travaillant étroitement avec nos
médecins nos pharmaciens mais aussi nos
associations dont je veux saluer
l'engagement et nous irons vacciner
toutes celles et ceux qui sont aussi le
plus loin des soins pour les collégiens
les lycéens les étudiants des campagnes
de vaccination spécifique seront
déployés dans les établissements
scolaires dès la rentrée
je veux m'adresser enfin à ceux qui
vaccinent lé premier c'est-à-dire en
janvier et février verront prochainement
leur taux d'anticorps décès et leur
immunité diminué je veux ici les
rassurer dès la rentrée une campagne de
rappel sera mise en place pour vous
permettre de bénéficier d'une nouvelle
injection selon le même système et dans
les mêmes conditions que la ou les
premières
les rendez vous pourront être pris dès
les premiers jours du mois de septembre
il n'est donc pas d'inquiétude à avoir
mais malgré le vaccin je vous demande à
toutes et tous de continuer à être
prudents et de continuer à respecter ces
gestes barrière contre le virus que vous
connaissez bien désormais en complément
de la vaccination nous allons devoir
mettre en place de nouvelles mesures
pour freiner le virus parce que le
niveau de vaccination y est encore très
insuffisant et que les hôpitaux sont
déjà sous forte progression l'état
d'urgence sanitaire sera déclaré dès
demain en conseil des ministres pour la
martinique et la réunion et un
couvre-feu sera instauré pour autant
dans l'hexagone sauf dans les
départements qui dépasserait un taux
d'incidence de 200 et verrait leur
hospitalisation augmenter ou des mesures
de freinage pourront être prise par le
préfet notre approche sera plus simple
partout nous aurons la même démarche
reconnaître le civisme et faire porter
les restrictions sur les non-vaccinés
plutôt que sur tous dès cette semaine
les contrôles aux frontières seront
encore renforcées pour les
ressortissants en provenance des pays à
risque avec un isolement contre un pour
les voyageurs non vaccinés dès le 21
juillet le pass sanitaire sera étendue
au lieu des loisirs et de culture
concrètement pour tous nos compatriotes
de plus de 12 ans il faudra pour accéder
à un spectacle un parc d'attractions un
concert ou un festival avoir été
vaccinés ou présenter un test négatif
récents ce pass est disponible sur
l'application tout senti peu vide mais
chacun peut utiliser la version papier
remise au moment de la vaccination à
partir du début du mois d'août
et cela parce qu'il nous faut faire
d'abord voté un texte de loi et le
promulguer à partir du début du mois
d'août donc le pass sanitaire
s'appliquera dans les cafés les
restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux mais aussi dans les avions
trains et cars pour les longs trajets là
encore seuls les vaccinés et les
personnes testées négatives pourront
accéder à ces lieux qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs clients usagers ou salariés
en fonction de l'évaluation de la
situation nous nous poserons la question
de l'extension du pass sanitaires à
d'autres activités encore cet automne
les fameux tests pcr seront rendus
payants
sauf prescription médicale et ceci afin
d'encourager la vaccination plutôt que
la multiplication des tests pour pouvoir
faire tout cela je convoquerai le
parlement en session extraordinaire à
partir du 21 juillet pour l'examen d'un
projet de loi qui déclinera ses
décisions vous l'avez compris la
vaccination n'est pas tout de suite
obligatoire pour tout le monde mais nous
allons étendre maximum le pass
sanitaires pour pousser le maximum
d'entre vous à aller vous faire vacciner
enfin nous continuerons d'agir pour
éviter l'apparition de variants qui
pourrait être plus dangereux encore que
le variant delta cela passe par un
projet immense mais indispensable est
désormais à notre portée vacciner le
monde la france depuis mars 2020 et à
l'initiative avec le programme act as
qui vise à la fois produire davantage de
vaccins et a donné aux pays les plus
pauvres
davantage de vaccins nous avons déjà
donné plus de deux millions et demi de
doses et d'ici la fin de l'année
donnant plusieurs dizaines de millions
de doses de vaccins nous contribuerons à
nous mobiliser
justement et à mobiliser tous nos
partenaires pour produire plus et donner
encore davantage aux pays les plus
pauvres en particulier dans les balkans
en afrique au proche et au moyen-orient
plusieurs pays sont aujourd'hui
fortement touchés et nous allons
accroître encore notre aide et je pense
particulièrement à la tunisie pour en
finir durablement avec la pandémie
nous devons vacciner partout je vous
l'avais dit l'année dernière nous
allions devoir vivre avec le virus
ce sera le cas tout au long de cette
année 2021 et sans doute pour plusieurs
mois encore de l'année 2022
même si le vaccin change beaucoup de
choses les semaines à venir seront donc
celle de la mobilisation pour bloquer le
virus et pour continuer de relancer
notre économie
l'été de mobilisation pour la
vaccination sera aussi un été de relance
gelé constaté au cours de mes récents
échanges avec vous partout en france
notre plan de relance se déploie un
rythme soutenu sur les 100 milliards
d'euros votés à l'automne dernier et
permet grâce à l'accord européen
historique d'il ya un an 40 milliards
ont ainsi été mobilisés sur le terrain
nous devons faire plus encore car plus
vite nous concrétiserons le plan de
relance plus fort sera notre rebond plus
relance plus efficace sera notre lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique
un tiers des crédits sont en effet ciblé
sur la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments sur les énergies décarbonées
sur l'automobile zéro émission tous les
secteurs qui concilie écologie et
économie écologie et progrès le
gouvernement et les préfets s'assureront
durant l'été de la bonne mise en oeuvre
des investissements sur le terrain nous
allons aussi faire le maximum pour lever
les contraintes qui pèsent sur les
secteurs justement qui sont les plus en
tension et sur vous tous d'abord le
manque de matières premières qu'il
s'agisse de bois d'acier de fer ou du
semi-conducteur ce qui a retardé de
nombreux chantiers et fait monter des
coups ensuite les pénuries de main
d'oeuvre
selon la banque de france près d'une
entreprise sur deux ne trouvent pas de
réponses à ces offres d'emploi il faut
ainsi tout faire ensemble sur le terrain
pour y répondre et responsabiliser
chacun notre priorité de l'été et de
l'automne est bien de retrouver non
seulement le niveau d'emploi d'avant
l'épidémie bendit de nous réinscrire
dans une trajectoire de plein emploi
si nous nous mobilisons pour nous
vacciner pour relancer l'économie alors
nous serons en mesure en septembre de
préparer collectivement notre avenir
il nous faudra en débattre de manière
apaisée démocratique
il nous faudra aussi prendre des
décisions
je veux d'ores et déjà partager avec
vous quelques convictions fortes
la première c'est la nécessité de moins
dépendre de l'étranger pour certains
produits essentiels certains services
certaines technologies
c'est la nécessité de retrouver le
chemin d'une indépendance française et
européenne parce que nous avons vécu
durant cette crise les conséquences de
la dépendance
grâce à l'action menée depuis 2010 est
nous sommes en train de réussir de nous
améliorer
des productions majeures pour la vie du
pays comme celles de paracétamol par
exemple ont été relocalisés en france
une usine géante de batteries pour nos
véhicules électriques va prochainement
ouvrir sur nos terres industrielles du
nord et préfigurer des investissements
massifs dans la transformation de
l'industrie automobile j'ai lancé le
mois dernier un plan d'investissement de
7 milliards d'euros pour l'innovation en
matière de santé d usine de la recherche
chez nous en france nous sommes depuis
deux ans la première nation européenne
du numérique et de la technologie
nous devons donc continuer d'investir et
encourager ces initiatives qui ont créé
plus de 160 mille emplois ce défi
désormais qui est le nôtre et de changer
d'échelle de généraliser partout cette
dynamique de redevenir une grande nation
de recherche
d'innovation d'agriculture et
d'industrie réindustrialiser réconcilier
la croissance et l'écologie de
production au niveau national la baisse
des impôts de production ainsi que celle
de l'impôt sur les sociétés que nous
avons décidé vont permettre d'accélérer
ce mouvement au niveau européen la
présidence française de l'union
européenne qui commencera le 1er janvier
2022 nous permettra de bâtir un agenda
commun d'indépendance industriel et
technologique à la rentrée après le
travail et les consultations en cours
nous déciderons d'un plan
d'investissement qui visera un objectif
bâtir la france de 2030 et faire émerger
dans notre pays et en europe
les champions de demain qui dans les
domaines du numérique de l'industrie
verte des biotechnologies ou encore de
l'agriculture dessineront notre avenir
la deuxième conviction c'est que nous
avons vu la force durant cette crise de
notre modèle social
ils à protéger nos entreprises nos
emplois notre culture de nombreux
secteurs exposés et la protéger notre
pouvoir d'achat durant la crise c'est un
joyau qu'il nous faut préserver ce
modèle social français repose sur un
fondement le travail sans travail pas de
production sans travail et sans
production pas de financement de notre
santé pas de financement du chômage
partiel pas de financement de nos
retraites
la priorité de la sortie de crise sera
donc la même que depuis le début du
quinquennat le travail et le mérite
c'est pour cela que nous allons
continuer d'investir dans la formation
tout au long de la vie dès cette rentrée
nous formons durablement plus de
demandeurs d'emploi qu'il ya quatre ans
mais ce n'est pas encore assez
j'ai demandé au gouvernement dès cette
rentrée de lancer un plan massif de
formation et de requalification des
chômeurs de longue durée
c'est pour cela que la réforme de
l'assurance chômage sera pleinement mis
en oeuvre dès le 1er octobre autour
d'une volonté simple
en france on doit toujours bien mieux
gagner sa vie en travaillant en restant
chez soi ce qui n'est actuellement pas
toujours le cas
c'est pour cela aussi que nous devrons
engager dès que les conditions
sanitaires seront réunies la réforme des
retraites
j'ai toujours tenu un langage de vérité
oui notre système est injuste
avec quarante deux régimes différents il
entretient des inégalités majeur et il
faudra aller vers plus de simplicité
pour plus de justice et donc les régimes
spéciaux devront être supprimés pour les
nouveaux employés dans ces secteurs
oui parce que nous vivons longtemps il
nous faudra travailler plus longtemps et
partir à la retraite plus tard à demain
pas brutalement pas de manière uniforme
car il faut prendre en compte la
difficulté des métiers mais
progressivement sur plusieurs années et
par un système qui fait la différence
selon le travail réellement exercées et
donc l'âge de départ doit être plus
tardif oui une vie de travail doit
offrir une pension digne et donc toute
retraite pour une carrière complète
devra être supérieure à 1000 euros par
mois voilà ce que je veux
en des termes clairs et simples pour
protéger les retraites actuelles et
celles de nos enfants sans augmenter les
impôts
il est juste et efficace de changer
notre système de retraite
j'ai entendu les débats sur le moment
faut-il faire cette réforme de ce mois
de juillet à la rentrée ou bien plus
tard alors si je demande aux
gouvernements de jean castex de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
sur ce sujet dès la rentrée je ne
lancerai pas cette réforme tant que
l'épidémie ne sera pas sous contrôle et
la reprise bien assuré la 3e conviction
enfin c'est que la nation doit une
réponse à ceux qui ont été le plus
touchés par la crise à notre jeunesse
qui a tant sacrifié alors qu'elle risque
et le pour elle même à notre ethnie qui
plus que les autres en train pour leur
fille
pour notre jeunesse nous devons
continuer d'investir investir dans la
petite enfance dans l'éducation
cela demeure plus que jamais notre
priorité en sortie de crise pour nos
jeunes adultes
nos étudiants comme nos jeunes actifs ou
nos jeunes qui sont peu formés
nous avons créé la plateforme un jeune
une solution mais poursuivront ce
programme qui a permis à deux millions
de jeunes de trouver une formation de
décrocher parfois un emploi de signer
souvent un contrat d'apprentissage
imaginez 526 mille contrats
d'apprentissage en 2020 ce qui est un
record pour amplifier cette dynamique je
présenterai à la rentrée le revenu
d'engagement pour les jeunes qui
concernera les jeunes sans emploi ou
formation et sera fondé sur une logique
de devoir est de droit quant à nos aînés
et nos concitoyens en situation de
handicap trop souvent confrontés à une
solitude sans solution nous leur devons
une grande ambition humaniste pour
l'autonomie un accompagnement renforcé
pour le maintien à domicile des maisons
de retraite moderniser accompagnement de
notre jeunesse meilleure prise en charge
des aînés c'est un nouveau pacte
français entre les générations qu'il
nous faut bâtir pour notre nation
cette ambition devra être financé et ce
ne sera pas par une hausse d'impôts
la russie je demeure constant avec la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation la
baisse des cotisations sociales
la diminution de l'impôt sur le revenu
ce qui représente 170 euros en plus par
mois pour un salarié au smic
nous avons assumé d'améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat est de baisser les impôts
une priorité pour les classes moyennes
que nous ne reviendrons pas en arrière
nos réformes ne seront pas davantage
financer en laissant filer la dette
la nouvelle génération doit déjà assumer
la dette écologique je n'ajouterai pas
ce fardeau de la dette financière la
seule solution
le seul moyen d'assurer ce nouveau pacte
est de travailler davantage d'investir
d'innover d'inventer d'améliorer notre
croissance est de continuer à réformer
réformer l'état comme nous avons
commencé à le faire avec la réforme de
la haute fonction publique et la
suppression de l'ena de simplifier le
mille-feuille territorial de simplifier
partout où c'est possible
l'action publique la seule solution est
de continuer à bousculer le système et
les positions établies les rentes les
statuts c'est ainsi que nous reprendrons
le contrôle de notre destin comme nation
c'est ainsi que nous reprendrons chacun
le contrôle de nos vies comme citoyen la
volonté que la france doit porter bien
celle-là reprendre le contrôle de notre
destin garantir à chacune et chacun des
nôtres qu'il pourra retrouver et de son
destin personnel professionnel familial
et civiques
bien des questions devront trouver des
réponses dans les mois qui viennent que
je n'ai pas ici abordée dans le cadre de
ce message ce soir j'ai bien entendu et
lu entendu l'inquiétude que fait naître
la montée d'une violence endémique dont
sont victimes les plus fragiles les
femmes souvent y compris dans le couple
de jeunes adolescents dans la rue et le
manque de respect à l'égard des forces
de l'ordre de sécurité j'ai entendu le
message porté à l'endroit de nos
institutions par l'abstention
impressionnante aux élections régionales
ou départementales et j'ai en tête les
questions qui portent sur les équilibres
de notre démocratie
devant toutes ces questions j'ai une
certitude
nous devons non seulement prolonger
notre effort mais le renouveler en
inventant chaque jour le nouveau modèle
que notre pays et le monde attendent et
des choses dans le monde sont en train
de bouger aussi grâce à des initiatives
que proposait soutient la france il
faudra se souvenir que c'est en ces
premiers jours de l'été 2021 que la
communauté internationale dans un effort
sans précédent a décidé d'une imposition
mondial des multinationales à 15 %
minimum mettant ainsi fin aux évasions
fiscales et aux paradis fiscaux
la france a été en
mira ligne et a contribué à faire bouger
l'europe et le monde plus chers
compatriotes cet été de retrouvailles et
de retour aux sources
cet été qui sera fait de moments amicaux
et familiaux devra donc être néanmoins
n'était de vigilance de lutte contre le
virus de vaccination j'ai confiance en
vous confiance en nous pour rester unis
serein et déterminé alors à la rentrée
nous auront rendez vous avec notre
avenir pour bâtir une france
indépendante qui ne vit pas dans la
nostalgie mais c'est prendre les
décisions nécessaires à sa destinée une
france conquérante qui a foi en la force
de sa jeunesse et n'a pas peur du futur
mais l'un vante une france unie qui sait
être solidaire civique responsable dans
l'épreuve comme dans la conquête
vive la république
et puis vraie france figaro live il est
donc 20h28 vous venez de suivre en
direct sur lefigaro.fr et sur notre page
youtube figaro live
l'allocution du président emmanuel
macron qui a duré donc quasiment une
demi heure un quart d'heure pour parler
de la situation sanitaire
et puis un quart d'heure pour évoquer
son bilan et puis les chantiers qui
restent dans ces derniers mois de deux
quinquennats ces dix prochains mois
avant la prochaine élection
présidentielle pour débriefer en direct
cette allocution nous sommes avec judith
waintraub bonjour bonjour
judith waintraub et donc journaliste
politique au figaro magazine
elle va décrypter avec nous ce discours
cette allocution et je suis également en
ligne avec vincent bordenave en skype en
liaison skype ont sûrement
vincent est ce que vous nous entendez
très bien vous êtes journaliste
scientifique donc au service sciences et
médecine du figaro et vous avez écouté
également avec attention les annonces
des manuels macro notamment pour faire
face au rebond épidémique on y reviendra
dans quelques instants
mais d'abord judith waintraub j'aimerais
savoir quels vous pensez de ce discours
et qu'est ce qu'on peut en retenir
alors ce qu'on peut en retenir
c'est qu'on se dirige lentement mais
sûrement vers la vaccination obligatoire
mais que tout en nous expliquant que
c'est une course de vitesse qui est un
langage nouveau parce que rappelez-vous
au début de la campagne vaccinale
c'était justement pas une course de
vitesse et s'agissait pas non plus 10 et
olivier ferrand de faire la constat du
show late bon maintenant on a reconnu
que c'était une course de vitesse tant
mieux en gros qu'il faut vacciner le
plus de monde possible partout dans
mieux aussi ça ça fait référence à la
décision toute récente d'autoriser les
gens à recevra une deuxième dose sur
leur lieu de vacances je vous rappelle
que les ars agences régionales de santé
bloquer ce qu'elle avait peur de plus
s'y retrouver dans leur fiche est
heureusement olivier ferrand a tapé du
poing sur la table pour le faire donc
tout le monde partout ça c'est très bien
il a choisi parmi les hypothèses qui
circulaient ces dernières heures
l'hypothèse haute en ce qui concerne le
caractère obligatoire de la de la
vaccination des gens en contact avec les
personnes les plus vulnérables
les soignants les personnels des ehpad
mais pas seulement les gens qui est à
vienne dans les ehpad ou à domicile
auprès des publics fragiles donc c'est
une couverture assez l'âge obligatoire
dès maintenant avec sanction le 15
septembre dont le temps de se faire
vacciner d'abord les douala
là on l'a enfin le temps de prendre deux
premières
la décision parce que je suppose que
quelqu'un qui n'aura qu'une 12 au 15
septembre ne seraient pas sanctionnés
puisqu'ils auraient fait la démarche
j'imagine voilà donc vaccin vaccination
obligatoire papa maintenant mais la
question se posera donc plus qu il
revient complètement sûr c'est sur ses
précédentes déclarations en novembre je
ne rendrai pas la vaccination
obligatoire ça c'est acté et donc sur le
plan sanitaire
on échappe et j'utilise ce mot à dessein
parce que moi j'en suis très contente
au retour de mesure parfaitement
inutiles comme le masque en expliquait
il en reste et rieur que certains maires
ont cru nécessaire de prendre
histoire de faire quelque chose fallait
absolument faire quelque chose alors que
les scientifiques et les médecins sont
d'accord et c'est un de leurs rares
points d'accord pour dire que ça ne sert
à rien en extérieur il ya deux régions
de france
parti de france qui échappe encore enfin
qui pour le coup non pas qu'ils
échappent mais qui tombe dedans c'est
sous cette obligation état d'urgence
sanitaire et couvre feu oui c'est la
martinique et la réunion des deux mains
sont dès demain et dans des zones où
cette houle vu où les gens sont très
très peu vaccinés notamment à la réunion
il ya de fortes réticences à la
vaccination
c'est pas le lieu d'explorer ça mais il
faudrait s'interroger aussi sur le rôle
des églises évangéliques dont certaines
freine des quatre fers
devant la vaccination voilà c'est de
leur droit au couvre-feu état d'urgence
mais nous non mais emmanuel macron a
laissé entendre lui de la même dit
d'ailleurs que selon les situations
locales les autorités les préfets
pourraient prendre
des mesures similaires donc c'est un
coût de près ça c'était pour la partie
sanitaire très vite
bon la partie et gardera pour les
rêveurs et je pense que ce qu'attendent
et surtout les gens savoir à quelle
sauce ils allaient être mangés
du point de vue du point de vue
sanitaire du point de vue des libertés
donc pas de réforme des retraites quand
il dit qu en lipides ministre a fini
comme ils viennent nous expliquer juste
avant que on en a pour jusqu'à une
partie de 2022 de vivre acte virus la
réforme des retraites
on ne leur a pas avant la présidentielle
en revanche dès le 1er octobre
application telle qu'elle a été votée de
la réforme de la peine qui a été décidée
de la réforme de l'assurance chômage ce
qui promet quelques remous sociaux parce
que je vous rappelle que tous les
syndicats étaient contre même avant la
crise sanitaire et puis une nouvelle
pour les jeunes ce revenu d'engagement
dont il reste à préciser les contours et
la cible qui sera mis en place dès la
rentrée alors dans le chat vous êtes
très très nombreux j'ai déjà du mal à
vous suivre en tout cas sûr sur la page
youtube de figaro live mais également
sur sur figaro.fr je vous en remercie je
vous salue d'abord sur lefigaro.fr
général
alcatraz delphine 51,6 show conan doyle
vous êtes nombreux donc tous les trois
ou tous les quatre a discuté ça parle
évidemment beaucoup de vaccination idem
sur le chat de notre page youtube figaro
live
donc les dos qui conseille à tout le
monde vous devriez tous vous faire
vacciner alors que roxanne et lilou nous
dit jamais je me ferai vacciner même
s'il faut que je reste enfermée chez moi
en tout cas frances marquise frances
marquise nous dit salah de mots de
maquereaux comme d'habitude quoi il va
continuer à nous mentir pour arriver à
ses fins faire gagner de la thune de
l'argent aux corporations de big pharma
donc évidemment le point principal en
tout cas le point des shops dans le dans
lé chat mais aussi j'imagine dans la
société française c'est le vaccin est
faut-il se faire vacciner ou pas est ce
que on peut contraindre juridiquement
quelqu'un à être vaccinés est ce que
cette extension du pass sanitaire que le
président vient d'annoncer dans
plusieurs lieux recevant du public comme
les bars les restos les as et en automne
les hôtels les musées les trains les
hôpitaux même les maisons de retraite il
va falloir présenter un pass sanitaire
des dès le mois d'août
vincent bordot n'avoue qui est
journaliste au service sciences et
médecine du figaro déjà première
question est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer vraiment en quoi consiste un
passani terre est ce que ça veut
vraiment dire qu'il faut se faire
vacciner pour avoir un pass sanitaires
et deuxième question est ce que cette
mesure
cette extension du passé ni terre était
nécessaire jusqu'à l'automne ya un
échappatoire au vaccin pour le fassent
vacciner sanitaires plus puisque il
suffit de présenter un test pcr ou
antigénique négatif de -2 72 heures le
sommes pour pouvoir rentrer là c'est par
exemple pour partir en vacances encore
sur l'étranger donc ce sera le cas pour
à partir du mois d'août pour aller au
restaurant pourra les centres
commerciaux pour aller au cinéma dans
les théâtres etc
donc on ya toujours une échappatoire à
la vaccination mais qui va disparaître à
l'automne vu que les tests pcr qui ne
seront plus remboursés l'été spéciale
qui ne sont pas prescrits
donc le test sanitaire va devenir de
fait vaccinale
va devenir de fête nationale est ce que
c'est une bonne chose le fêter que la
vaccination c'est le chemin le plus
rapide de sortir de la crise c'est pas
une formule on le voit on voit très bien
dans les pays qui ont commencé leurs
concurrentes d'avancé par rapport à nous
sur leurs campagnes de vaccination comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui au royaume uni
où il ya une augmentation du nombre de
cas mais qui ne s'accompagne pas par une
augmentation des hospitalisations et des
décès liés au co vide et ça c'est un des
résultats fin c'est le résultat d'une
campagne vaccinale mené tambour battant
avec il me semble j'ai plus les chiffres
exacts antenne une a4 plus 85% de la
population adulte qui a déjà reçu une
première dose au royaume uni et cette
membrane qui montre de premiers
résultats portant sur ce qui est le plus
important à savoir les cas graves et des
hospitalisations juste ajouter quelques
malaises disant de ce point de vue là
d'ailleurs ce que divassa est très
important l'accélération de la
circulation du vide du virus ne se
traduit pas par une augmentation des
hospitalisations là où elle a commencé
avant la france
il a cité la grande bretagne aurait pu
citer il sera elle aussi c'est pareil le
nombre de morts ne bouge pas et ça non
seulement emmanuel macron ne l'a pas dit
mais il a dit le contraire il a dit le
nombre d'hospitalisations va augmenter
et c'est un contresens alors d'avoir dit
ça c'est une stratégie c'est une
stratégie c'est une stratégie sur
laquelle on doit s'interroger s'il dit
non à plus long terme ce que disent les
il s'appuie sur le rapport du conseil
scientifique qui explique que si la
vaccination rester à l'état actuel on
aurait pendant un temps donné jusqu'à la
rentrée une augmentation du nombre de
cas et pas d'hospitalisation mais le
sait cette augmentation de cas
s'accompagnerait à partir du mois de
septembre octobre par un nombre une
augmentation du nombre de cas graves qui
serait plus qu'ils soient trop
importants pour être géré par un système
de soins et qui prévoirait donc une voix
une vague similaire à celle d'automne
20 pour celles de la rentrée de 21,1
avec la vaccination qui est celle
attendue au vu des rythmes actuels alors
conan doyle sur le chat du figaro.fr
soulève une question intéressante si
vous faites vacciner contre votre gré là
on est dans l'illégalité ou comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure je dit macron
s'était prononcé en défaveur d'une
vaccination obligatoire en tout cas au
début de la crise sanitaire à l'automne
dernier est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut je vire et changer de braquet et et
imposer cette vaccination à ce qui est
ce que ce serait légale bon là c'est ce
qu'il a dit c'est la question de la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous se
posera sans donner de date
il ya une controverse entre
constitutionnaliste guy est dû au
caractère provisoire des autorisations
de mise sur le marché des vaccins
apparemment comme ça a été fait
extrêmement rapidement avec moult
précautions et je rappelle qu'il ya plus
de trois milliards d'êtres humains qui
ont été vaccinés et qu' on est on a la
certitude aujourd'hui que les éventuels
effets indésirables des vaccins et
accidents vaccinaux sont bien moindres
que les effets indésirables de l'aco
vide
c'est à dire que le la balance
bénéfices risques est très très
largement en faveur du bénéfice malgré
ça le statut juridique des vaccins ouvre
la voie à des recours parce que c'est
pas des vaccins a autorisé de manière
définitive
est ce que les agences qui délivre les
autorisations peuvent accélérer pour
lever cet obstacle juridique sans doute
il faut voir mais à mon avis au delà de
la controverse juridique et des actions
qu'il y aura forcément parce que
l'hivernage depuis le début de la crise
on a vu des perquisitions au fait
jusque au domicile du premier ministre à
celui d'ulysse de la santé est-ce que la
la la pression sociétale de l'opinion en
faveur de la vaccination qui est quand
même déjà assez forte ne suffira pas à
régler le problème a remis par delà les
et les obstacles juridiques
alors j'essaye toujours de vous lire
mais c'est très compliqué dans le chatt
youtube figaro live vous êtes très très
nombreux en tout cas de ce que je vois
l'opinion en tout cas qui qui sort de ce
chat les français qui commande donc ils
disent pour la plupart nouveau vaccin
obligatoire et centre est révulsée par
par cette mesure
pour l'instant évidemment il n'a pas
annoncé l'obligation vaccinale pour pour
tous les français uniquement
comme l'a dit judith en préambule
uniquement pour les personnels soignants
ou les personnels qui sont au contact de
personnes fragiles vincent bordot nav
est ce qu'on peut faire un point
justement sur la vaccination française
et surtout sur ce sentiment de méfiance
envers les vaccins on voit qu'il est
très ancrée dans la tête des personnes
qui nous suivent sur notre chat youtube
quelle est la proportion vraiment de
français défiants envers les vaccins
c'est compliqué de faire la part entre
les vrais anti vaccins qui quoi qu'il
arrive seront jamais vacciné et ne font
pas vacciner leurs enfants et les
personnes qui peuvent avoir des doutes
avec des vaccins qui ont été fabriqués
on est passé en un temps record et et
qui va donc attendre d'eux des preuves
sur les absences a fait ce monde bien
alors pour le moment ce qu'on voit en
tout cas c'est que la part des anti
vaccin n'a pas été suffisant pour
freiner la vaccination mais comme
toujours environ 500 mille doses qui
seront injectées quotidiennement dans le
pays mais il ya quand même un
ralentissement très important sur des
premières injections donc les personnes
qui souffrent soit blanc leur première
dose de vaccin qui commence dans cette
démarche a un style un peu plus de 200
milles injection
par jour l'enjeu de ces nouvelles
mesures c'est justement de redonner de
l'allant pour arriver à atteindre les
objectifs de 45 millions il me semble à
la fin à la fin août
et pour ça il faut donner un coup de
booster supplémentaires et donc sur les
personnes qui s'opposent aux vaccins on
remarque quand même que depuis la
campagne de début de la campagne de
vaccination le nombre de personnes qui
refusent et un vaccin anti kobe n'a
cessé diminué on est aujourd'hui aux
alentours de 20 à 30% et c'est quelque
chose qu'on remarque quand on analyse
classe d'âge par classes d'âge les les
pourcentage de personnes ayant reçu un
vaccin on plafonne toujours aux
alentours des 80 % l'enjeu des mesures
annoncées aujourd'hui c'est justement
dépasser ce plafond
particulièrement chez les publics les
plus fragiles et plus de 2 puis de 60
ans et également chez en insistant
également chez les personnes dessous
merci vincent je lis une question de
faim c'est pas vraiment une question
mais de pithiviers fr sur le chat de
youtube qui nous dit donc qu'il nous
fait part de son commentaire à l'issue
de cette allocution du président depuis
ce soir 20h macron a réussi à faire
voyager des millions de français en
corée du nord
judith waintraub à ce que vous comprenez
ces commentaires de cet internaute alors
moi je suis libéral amoureuse la liberté
la liberté quand on vit en société
suppose quelques contraintes pour les
libéraux qui aiment la théorie je
signale qu adam smith le père du
libéralisme était pour la vaccination
friedrich von hayek aussi donc il faut
pas faire de ça un problème de dogme oui
se vacciner est une contrainte mais
quand on vit en société je le répète il
y a des contraintes et parler de corée
du nord
à propos du vaccin mériterait co qu'on
paye à cet internaute
hier encore un petit voyage en corée du
nord si c'était possible
un petit stage en corée du nord tout à
fait voilà pour pour vous pithiviers fr
merci de nous suivre et si vous voulez
répondre à judith waintraub je relaierai
votre réponse si je la vois pas ce qu'il
ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de monde
qui interagit dans ce dans ce chat
vincent bordot n'avons va on va aborder
une annonce donc ce soir qui était assez
attendue puisqu'elle est débattu depuis
très longtemps faim depuis plusieurs
jours maintenant dans les médias sur les
plateaux télé c'est la faction
vaccination obligatoire des soignants et
des personnes qui sont en contact avec
des personnes vulnérables face à la
maladie du coc vie de 19
pourquoi il ya une partie une si grande
partie des soignants qui hésitent encore
à se faire vacciner
c'est intéressant parce que ce non
recours à la vaccination chez les
soignants il est pas seulement propre
coli dont on retrouve aussi dans le dans
le cadre des campagnes de vaccination
contre contre la grippe saisonnière et
il est très différent en fonction des
professions c'est à dire que les
médecins ont tendance à se vacciner
assez largement par contre les aides
soignants les infirmiers ont des taux de
vaccination beaucoup beaucoup plus
faible
pourquoi si on avait la réponse ce trait
on trouvera la solution mais il ya une
défiance qui existent quoi qu'il arrive
dans dans la société qui se ressent
particulièrement dans six ans il est
aussi dans ces professions est en tout
cas c'est un vrai impact est ce un vrai
danger pour pour les patients et pour
les
et pour les pensionnaires des maisons de
soins quand on regarde que dans les
ehpad à près de 40% des personnels
soignants et non soignants ont ils
recours au vaccin
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
inquiétant et quand on sait que jeunes
et des personnes âgées sur les personnes
les plus vulnérables
donc l'enjeu la vaccination obligatoire
il s'est imposé de fait parce qu'on n'a
pas réussi à dépasser plein de merde qui
a sans doute à un processus de 2 mai à
coups de fin il faudra il faudra il
faudra réfléchir à pour comment est ce
qu'on n'a pas réussi à convaincre ces
gens qui pourtant si on était en
première ligne de la crise ont vu des
gens mourir à cause de cette maladie et
qui n'ont pas jugé bon de se protéger
peut-être qu'on n'a pas insisté sur
l'enjeu de protéger réseau quand on est
un camps ce vaccin on se protège pas
soit là mais on protège aussi les hôtes
en réduisant le risque de transmission
le président la république l'a dit mais
quand on est vaccinés on à tout moment
de risque de transmettre le comique
quand on est pas on a peut-être un peu
trop insister sur la protection
habituelle et ce qui n'a pas convaincu
les personnels de soins rentrer dans
cette démarche d'intro moi j'ajouterai
une explication culturel on a parlé tout
à l'heure de la martinique
oui la réunion qui sont soumises à
l'état d'urgence ya nouveau couvre-feu
je vais pas vous refaire le sketch des
inconnus sur les ehpad
c'est facile que le connaissez de mai
mais il ya énormément de personnel des
ehpad qui vient d'outre-mer et qui
partagent cette réussite réticence à la
vaccination
alors je lui parlais tout à l'heure des
églises évangéliques ce n'est pas la
seule raison il faudrait peut-être aussi
se pencher sur la dimension culturelle
de la chose alors sur le chat du
figaro.fr vous êtes toujours aussi
nombreux et ça débat encore une fois
beaucoup de la vaccination
je vais vous lire un petit peu donc j'ai
d'abord merci de commenter non mais le
principe bénéfices tricks que ça veut
toujours pas rentrer dans le crâne de
certains alors bon et rire hier car 38
qui répondent oui mais personne n'est
obligé de voyager cij qui lui répond je
suis vacciné mais je suis contre la
société totalitaire qui se met en place
on voit bien encore que le débat se
cristallise toujours autour de 7,2 cette
obligation vaccinale vaccinale ou pas
alors il faut rappeler que emmanuel
macron n'a pas ainsi
or et cette obligation vaccinale pour
tous les publics encore pour l'instant
vincent bordenave journaliste
scientifique vient de vient d'évoquer
donc la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants pour l'instant ce qui sera
obligatoire pour tous les français tous
les publics français c'est de présenter
son pass sanitaires à l'entrée de
d'endroits qui rassemble plus de 50
personnes alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est des
amis ses 5000 ou 1000 même il me semble
les concerts de plus de 1000 personnes
50 personnes ça devient vraiment ça
concerne beaucoup de choses à la fois
les réunions familiales or la destot là
il va y avoir un problème pratique les
restaurateurs je sais pas si vous avez
fait l'expérience d'aller d'aller au
restaurant je crois vous pense pas qu'on
vous ait demandé nom de mon point de vue
la paix ou quoi que ce soit donc déjà
ils sont extrêmement 10h à faire ça en
gros est ce qu'on va pouvoir les
transformer en flic
je n'en suis pas sûr on peut comme les
deux de nos internautes que vous avez
cités pousser des cris d'orfraie en
disant que nos libertés sont piétinées
on peut aussi dire que puisqu'il faut
accepter des contraintes et donc des
restrictions des libertés pour des
raisons sanitaires
autant y aller carrément parce que cette
phase intermédiaire que manuel macron se
donne précisément parce qu'il a peur de
ce genre de réaction et puis parce que
ne nous le cachons pas la présidentielle
et dans neuf mois et que qui est
particulièrement contre la vaccination
obligatoire et qui a été contre à
l'assemblée
la vaccination des soignants c'est pire
opposant le rassemblement national
marine le pen
la france a soumises jean luc mélenchon
donc il ya quand même une lecture
politique de tout ça emmanuel macron a
peur des réactions à neuf mois de la
présidentielle
mais s'il considère que c'est une vraie
urgence
pourquoi attendre alors t'es chez ati
blâma qui me meut invectives pas moi qui
m'en bekhti qui m'interpelle directement
dans le chat du figaro.fr je vous
remercie je vais vous lire bruno dre
donc c'est non non non non moi je suis
pour le vaccin obligatoire quand une
fraction de français font de l'anti vax
par idéologie et j'ai deux bords et 6 ch
qui continuent de débattre sur les
effets secondaires du vaccin
donc j'ai de bord qui nous dit non ils
ne sont pas en phase de tests jusqu'en
2023 c'est juste des études
complémentaires et 6 ch qui nous déclare
jamais avec un vaccin n'a provoqué
autant d'effets secondaires et de décès
vincent bordot nabe est ce que vous
pouvez faire un point sur les effets
secondaires connus des vaccins contre le
coc vite 19 oui alors je crois savoir
qu'elle soit les données qui montrent
que ce jamais un vaccin n'a eu autant
d'effets secondaires de décès parce que
c'est toi l'inversion un vaccin qui est
extrêmement sûre on a plusieurs vaccins
disponibles en france il ya deux
principaux qui sont suivis de ferries
arbouille ait acquis un max un arn
messagers c'est à dire on va donner
l'information génétique du virus à un
autre système immunitaire pour qu'ils
apprennent à se défendre contre lui et à
l'autre vaccin qui le vaccin astrazeneca
qui est quand même en perte de vitesse
justement parce que lui harang a
rencontré quelques difficultés c'est à
dire qu'il a provoqué de très rares
effets secondaires d'être en pause des
caillots sanguins chez chez dans le jeu
j'ai pu les chiffres exacts en tête de
pharmacovigilance mais on est à quelques
dizaines d'individus pour des millions
de personnes avaient accès alors non
seulement il ya eu des essais cliniques
de phase 1 2 3 habituel c'est à dire on
va tester l'efficacité du vaccin son
innocuité et son efficacité à grande
échelle mais surtout ça a été dit tout à
l'heure on a des millions de personnes à
travers le monde qui ont été vaccinés on
se rend compte que les effets
secondaires sont les milliards promis la
lyre de personnes ont été vaccinées à
travers le monde et que les effets
secondaires sont extrêmement rares
à l'échelle et même mon psy en dessous
se place à cette échelle ils sont
quasiment inexistants donc les données
sont plus que rassurante là dessus et je
rajouterais que il n'est jamais arrivé
dans l'histoire de la vaccination que
des effets secondaires se déclenchent
des années après la paix l'injection
qu'il ya des effets secondaires c'est
dans les mois qui suivent diffus verger
ctions on a dépassé cette phase là et
donc on a quand même une certaine
certaines assurances de la sécurité de
ces vaccins y compris des vaccins est
reine et j'ajouterais aussi un point qui
est très important c'est que même si
c'est des vaccins nous vous sur lequel
on a travaillé extrêmement rapidement
on a un recul de plusieurs dizaines
d'années dessus parce que les vaccins et
rentrent sont connus depuis depuis une
dizaine d'années dans le milieu
scientifique et les premières personnes
à avoir un jeu avoir reçu une injection
de vaccin à rennes l'ont reçu un don au
début des années 2000 et pour la plupart
d'entre eux se portent supporte très
bien ils sont aujourd'hui les premiers
défenseurs d'ailleurs de ces vaccins et
c'est bien la preuve que les effets
secondaires à long terme ne sont pas
sûrs par m
alors tu es châtie blâme ajustements
conclut un peu 7,7 cette réponse de
vincent barroso n'a en dix ans les
antilles vers les antilles vagues ce
sont des égoïstes anti patriotique et il
ya qu'à faut qu'on qui arrive dans le
chat du figaro.fr il ya qu'à faut qu'on
qui nous dit bonsoir allez tous vous
faire vacciner en majuscules effet voilà
le message le message est passé en tout
cas vous aurez des réfractaires dans le
tchat
yakafocon préparez vous à vos arguments
sur le chat du figaro.fr parce que vous
êtes très nombreux également sur sur la
page youtube figaro l'aide je vous en
remercie je vous rappelle qu'on est en
direct ensemble pour débriefer les
dernières annonces des manuels macron
depuis maintenant vingt minutes nous
sommes en direct nous allons rester
encore quelques dizaines de minutes
un petit quart d'heure pour rester et
pour répondre à toutes vos questions
n'hésitez pas si vous avez des questions
judith waintraub du service politique du
figaro magazine est là pour vous
répondre également en liaison skype
vincent bordot naf du service sciences
et médecine du figaro judith waintraub
je voudrais revenir sur le
début de l'allocution du président
emmanuel macron il a commencé on va dire
sur le premier quart d'heure qui
concernait la situation sanitaire en
france il a commencé un petit peu par
s'auto contre annaba on a eu droit au
numéro d'autosatisfaction rituel on a
touché bien on a tout fait mieux que les
autres
pas un quart d'heure j'ai calculé ça
dure et s'habiller en intro du val ardue
quart d'heure sanitaires on va dire elle
a démarré on a on a tous très bien fait
et en particulier moi j'ai eu vraiment
raison de ne pas reconfigurer il l'a dit
au message subliminal vous savez fin
janvier quand tous les scientifiques
la plupart des scientifiques hurlait
qu'on allait
à voir les dizaines de milliers de morts
oui mais c'est le numéro habituel
il a aussi fait le numéro sur l'économie
d'ailleurs en disant qu'avec nos 6 % de
croissance prévu on était parmi les tous
premiers ou les tout premiers d'europe
ce qui est vrai d'ailleurs mais ce qui
correspond aussi au fait qu on a été
parmi ceux qui à droite où la croissance
est tombé le plus bas
donc c'est facile de remonter donc doc
évidemment la marge pour remonter
beaucoup plus grande
l'allemagne sera 300 camps nous on sera
à 6 mais elle est tombée brook ou
beaucoup moins bas que nous l a qu'au
fil des mois et d'une autre façon et
elle a aidé d'une autre façon aussi on
peut pas dire moi mais elle a aidé
davantage des entreprises que les
individus
chez nous tout a été mis quand même sur
le chômage partiel
et d'ailleurs on sort de là avec un
chômage de 8% le président s'est aussi
félicité du nombre extraordinaire de
création d'un point on est toujours à 8%
de chômage ce qui n'est pas mal mais il
reste des tas de gens qui sont en
chômage partiel le chômage allemand est
à 6 % chômage partiel sur la situation
sanitaire vincent bordot navas que le
président macron a eu raison de s'auto
féliciter au début comme on vient de
l'évoquer avec judith waintraub est ce
que ces mesures qui vient de prendre
arrive à temps est-ce qu'on arrivera à
faire face à la quatrième vague qui se
profile devant nous ce qu'on arrivera à
faire face la quatrième fois que je suis
junior il est ce qu'il y aura une
quatrième bague aussi on ne fait pas la
réponse à cette question et même aucun
épidémiologie cette réponse parce que on
n'est pas en capacité de le savoir
comment est-ce que l'augmentation de
l'incidence du nombre de 15 sur ce se
manifestera se transformer à une
augmentation des formes graves des
hospitalisations et des décès et donc on
est un peu dans une situation
d'expectative d'expectative en regardant
l'angleterre en espérant que ce qui se
passe continue continue la même manière
qu'eux il n'y a pas de ne pas une
explosion des hospitalisations expliquer
une explosion des cas graves et des
décès et est ce que les mesures sont
annoncées
trop tard en tout cas elles ont un effet
vu que là le 6 de dr libre est saturé ce
soir est pris d'assaut pour pour se
faire vacciner
le fait est qu'on n'avait pas
suffisamment de doses de vaccin au début
de l'année pour vacciner tout le monde
qu'il fallait y aller crescendo que la
vaccination commençait à marquer le pas
et que pour la première fois depuis
début la campagne de vaccination il y
avait énormément de doses en attente le
président la république a parlé de 9
millions de doses en attente et c'est ce
qui correspond aux sons modo au
différentiel entre le ce qui restait du
nombre de doses du mois de juin et les
noms de personnes qui sont vaccinées
depuis début juillet les doses qu'on a
plus qu'on a pu recevoir donc sauf coup
de ce coup de fouet à premiers échos
qu'on peut avoir cela semble marcher en
tout cas il a il interpelle et sa droite
les réactions sur les réseaux et on
verra s'il est suffisant je l'espère et
objectivement quand même d'un point de
vue purement scientifique on peut se
réjouir d'avoir des vaccins aussi
efficace aussi sûrs en un temps aussi
rapide et et qui peuvent nous permettre
d'envisager un automne 2021 bien plus
serein que ce fut le cas il y à il ya un
an on a un outil
ça a été dit pas présent à public et
pour le coup c'est vrai on a un outil
qui nous permet de sortir de cette crise
on a un outil qui nous permettra de ne
par vider et confinement ne pas avoir à
faire un choix entre confiné et laisser
des gens des chars mourir ou ou être
intubés en réanimation cet outil ces
vaccins et dont il faut fouiller le plus
le plus fort possible dessus j'ajoute
aussi un point qui était important qui
est vacciné le monde ça a été dit par le
reprise en un public c'est pas là aussi
c'est pas la formule parce que le danger
que
sinon on se protège du du du virus le
laisser se propager dans d'autres pays
et voir apparaître de nouveaux variants
qui eux pour échapper au vaccin ce qui
n'est pas le cas encore aujourd'hui
c'est un c'est un point important et sur
lequel il faudra il faut aussi être
rédigée vous glisser un mot à cette
occasion de renforcer les contrôles en
feront aux frontières le mou renforcée
c'est un peu rire parce que vu qu'ils
étaient quasiment inexistants
jusqu'à présent si michel barnier a
raconté qu'il s'était fait contrôler un
revenant beau c'est peut-être qu'ils ont
reconnu sony on va contrôler le verdict
ça il racontera que les contrôles sont
effectifs il est temps globalement même
si effectivement cette fois pour les
pays entre européens la sentence et non
pour les pays et non en union européenne
qui aura renforcement trop je l'aï
retrait de bruxelles il a été contrôlé
clément bonne dizaine et les ports n'est
ce pas d'éviter d'aller en espagne
portes de la tuque j'ai regardé les
chiffres de vaccination en espagne les
les plus de 75 ans c'est presque du 100%
de vacciner ou en découle le fossé avec
nous la différence on a la chance
d'avoir cet instrument il faut y aller
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure de
l'autorisation beaucoup trop tardive
donner aux gens de recevoir leur seconde
dose humana première maintenant sur les
lieux de vacances et par et pas au
domicile trop attendu il faut faire ça
massivement deuxième chose pour laquelle
on a beaucoup trop attendu c'est de
communiquer aux médecins la liste de
leurs patients vulnérables non vaccinés
alors la cnil la commission nationale
informatique et libertés vient enfin de
donner l'autorisation mais tenez vous
bien
ils ont le droit de savoir les médecins
mais ils ont pas le droit d'essayer de
convaincre les personnes en question de
se faire vacciner on marche sur la tête
vincent bordot neuf il ya une personne
dans le chat et c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
abordé cette question mais effectivement
ma croix a laissé entendre qu'il y
aurait donc une troisième dose qui
serait possible et qu'on pourrait
prendre rendez vous pour les personnes
qui ont déjà terminé leur leur schéma
vaccinal depuis plusieurs mois qui
pourrait prendre rendez vous dès le mois
de septembre pour une troisième dose est
ce qu'on pourrait revenir sur les
avantages les bénéfices de cette
troisième dose vincent bordot nad ali
amar appel puisque d'une troisième dose
c'est une nuance mais c'est quand même
oui c'est ça martine et ses nuances mais
qui est quand même importante parce que
et ce n'est pas pour tout le monde
en tout cas de ce qui fait dans certains
pays ces deux quarts en israël
et ce qui est un peu ce qui sort un peu
la littérature scientifique c'est que
pour les personnes les plus fragiles ou
d'un système littéraire est le plus
faible
là encore on est toujours sur les mêmes
publics les personnes les plus âgées
le taux d'anticorps
qui est produit par l'arrestation par la
bastille vaccination ne viendrais trop
faible au bout de quelques mois et il
faudrait il faudrait se rappelle pour
rebooster un peu le système immunitaire
c'est c'est une possibilité on a
vraiment encore pas assez de recul pour
savoir si ce sera nécessaire pour
l'ensemble de la population suisse sera
nécessaire par rapport à de nouveaux
variants les données la littérature sont
scientifiques et des retours qu'on peut
avoir sont même plutôt rassurant dans
dans l'autre sens les deux doses de des
vaccins et particulièrement des vaccins
et semble très robuste sur le long terme
parce que la réponse immunitaire c'est
les anticorps les anticorps c'est qu'une
partie de la réponse immunitaire c'est
ce qui est la partie visible mais le
site a une équipe militaire est beaucoup
plus complexe il yad'autres d'autres
mécanismes qui se met en branle après
après dans notre corps et qui permet de
neutraliser le virus donc
donc je pense que c'est vraiment là
c'est vraiment une annonce qui vise à
rassurer à dire ceux qui veulent rester
vacciner il y aura des vaccins pour vous
et ceux qui ont peur à la rentrée d'être
d'être vulnérable au virus ne vous
inquiétez pas on vous permettra d'avoir
une troisième dose donc ce rappel mais
il s'agit pas de le rendre obligatoire
pour pour toucher qui ont déjà deux
doses de vaccin et surtout il sera
peut-être pas indispensable pour la
plupart d'entre nous on attend de voir
pour ça et je suis je répète je les
premières données indiquent même plutôt
le contraire
abdeslam bustaffa qui nous rejoindre sur
le chat du figaro live sur youtube et
qui nous demandent est ce que le
confinement était instaurée parce que
j'ai raté le début
non le confinement n'ya pas instaurer à
part si vous vivez à la réunion où
remarquer martinique où le couvre-feu
revient dès demain dans ces deux
territoires en revanche ce qui nous
concerne en france métropolitaine c'est
que dès le 21 juillet le pass and iter
est élargi aux endroits recevant du
public
de moins de 5 pour les rassemblements de
moins de 50 personnes de plus de 50
personnes pardon et puis début août on
n'a pas encore la date parce qu'il faut
que ce soit votée ce sera élargie à tous
les lieux recevant du public
les bars les restaurants les cinémas les
salles de sport alors il ya paris dès
que les all blacks seconde version n'est
pas des petits commerces
mais il a fait ça effectivement il a
parlé des centres commerciaux est ce que
ça concerne également les supermarchés
on ne sait pas il faudra peut-être des
précisions notamment avant début août
avant cette cette entrée via surtout ce
sera dur texte de loi qui doit être doté
tout sera session extraordinaire
présenté par le premier ministre c'est
un peu comme ça que ça a fonctionné tout
au long de cette crise sanitaire le
président annonce un calendrier et puis
c c'est le premier ministre qui donne
les kids
voilà qui donne les dates exactes et les
modalités alors rémy prost qui commente
également sûr sur youtube
rémy prost book pardon j'ai écorché
votre pseudo intégral oui j'ai une
question est-ce que l'on peut vivre
encore librement comme en 2021
ou faudra-t-il montré un pass sanitaires
pour cela et maxime qui nous déclare
faut arrêter avec votre le vaccin n'est
pas obligatoire car le pass sanitaires
pour aller faire ses courses en sachant
que les tests pcr et autres deviendront
payants c'est une obligation dissimulé
oui ça revient à ça ça revient
complètement has a tout à fait mais
pourquoi ne pas avoir dit clairement
alors eva c'est la question qu'on peut
poser et je pense avoir apporté les
éléments de réponse en rappelant que la
présidentielle et dans neuf mois
justement on peut faire un petit point
juste sur au moins les 15 dernières
minutes de ce discours un qui était en
deux parties donc une première partie
sur la réponse à cette crise sanitaire
et cette quatrième vague et une seconde
partie consacrée au bilan du quinquennat
de macron et puis les possibles sur
leurs perspectives
voilà alors évidemment il y avait un
point qui était extrêmement attendu
c'était la réforme des retraites tout en
disant qu'elle est absolument
indispensable et van hulle matheron l'a
enterré en tout cas jusqu'à la
présidentielle alors il ya parlé dans
part
de réunir les partenaires sociaux mais
il ya du temps que la crise sanitaire la
crise suscite cette épidémie fardeau ne
sera pas sous contrôle tant que la crise
sanitaire ne sera pas finie et un peu
plus tôt dans son allocution il avait
dit qu'il vendrait pas fini avec l'aco
vide de toute l'année 2021 et d'une
partie de l'année 2022
normalement ça devrait tenir pour ne pas
avoir la réforme des retraites jusqu'à
l'été au président basquiat bras ou en
avril ou en mai de nouvelles penser
qu'elle fera partie de son progrès elle
sera à l'évidence dans son programme
d'où le dégagement relativement longs
qui l'y a consacré donc ça c'est une
réforme qui fâche qui saute
en revanche l'application au 1er octobre
de la réforme de l'assurance chômage est
un chiffon rouge pour les syndicats qui
était absolument tous contre y compris
la cfdt alors dans cette partie de son
intervention
emmanuel macron a clairement visé
l'électorat de droite il l'a dit mes
deux fils conducteurs enfin je peux le
veau qui les employés mais mais de deux
piliers de bons programmes évidemment
s'exprimant en tant que candidat à sa
propre succession seront le travail et
le mérite qui sont vraiment des valeurs
hackers de la toile marqueur de la
droite d'où cette traduction concrète
par la danse de la mise en application
de la réforme de l'assurance chômage il
a dit clairement
qu'on pouvait encore en france gagner
davantage grâce aux allocations diverses
et variées qu'en travaillant et que ça
n'était pas normal et même si la donne
est un peu un gage un petit gages à son
aile gauche sur le revenu d'engagement
pour les jeux pour les jeunes qui sera
mis en place dès septembre dont on
connaît pas encore les contours ni on ne
sait pas non plus à quel public quel
public précisément ça ça va s'adresser
est-ce que c'est tous les jeunes pas
tous les jeunes tout ça reste à préciser
clairement il continue tirant les leçons
des régionales où les sortants de droite
ont été réélus très confortablement à la
tête de la région je penserai à valérie
pécresse pense évidemment à xavier
bertrand et puis surtout à laurent
wauquiez qui a fait le plus beau score
parmi les sortants de droite même si
nationalement le plus le record revient
à une socialiste
carole delga va en tout cas les trois
corps étaient était très confortable des
victoires sans appel
donc ça veut dire que
la droite n'a pas dit son dernier mot
pour la présidentielle il en tient
compte et c'est à son électorat qui
s'adresse et quand il a parlé il a
également parlé de la renault de
relocaliser à sion d'industrie
pharmaceutique saas etc pour grappiller
des voix aussi à droite
c'est un discours qui s'en sortent grâce
à ses effets il fait vivre et la vivre
souverainiste ça c'est une affection
qu'il avait prises dès les européennes
lui qui est tellement pro européens
avaient commencé à introduire la notion
de souveraineté nationale même s'il a
plutôt souveraineté européenne est enfin
là il parle clairement de la
réintroduction d'entreprises en france
est ce qu'il va joindre les actes à la
parole
je signale juste il a parlé de la
production de paracétamol qui est parti
les les patrons des grands labos vous
disent que la raison pour laquelle la
france a cessé de produire c'est
évidemment question gagner de l'argent
de coût du travail
coût du travail votre cher en france
pour produire localement mais pas
seulement et il ya aussi une raison de
sueur transposition des normes
écologiques
la france est la championne des
contraintes renforcer dès que l'union
européenne vote
une règle pour préserver l'environnement
nous on en rajoute et ça aussi a
lourdement contribué à faire fuir les
labos or il a parlé
de l'objectif écologique à plusieurs
reprises alors je voulais également dans
le chat ou jours et je vois que ça débat
toujours sur la vaccination
l'obligation pas obligation est
également sur les tests pcr qui
effectivement ne seront plus remboursés
les tests pcr de confort comme comme on
appelle ça est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un mot vincent bordot 9 qu'est
ce que c'était que ces tests pcr de
confort et pourquoi ils ne seront plus
remboursés à partir du mois d'octobre il
me semble oui c'est ça à l'automne
bardot à l'au-delà badamia date c'est
qu'aucun séparer de tests pcr de confort
commencé comme c'est inconfortable de de
subir ces tests il s'agit en fait des
têtes déteste qu'on pouvait faire avant
de voyager de prendre l'avion pour
partir à l'étranger avant de d'aller au
stade pour depuis que les stades ont pu
réouvrir où à chaque événement qui
rassemble des personnes donc un festival
un concert et qui sont à prévoir les
grands-parents appartient on prenait pas
le un avion problème il ya beaucoup de
gens qui lui donc c'est si c'est pour ça
que le déremboursement de ces tests
pause pose une question pour pour toutes
ces situations là des gens qui voulaient
aller ne pas prendre de risques avant
d'aller voir nos grands-parents des
rassemblements familiaux mais là il n'y
avait pas d'obligation le faire mais on
le faisait de bon gré et l'objectif tout
simplement c'est de forcer ces gens à ne
plus compter sur ces tests mais à avoir
recours au vaccin et dès aujourd'hui
parce que entre le pour avoir un
passeport sanitaires il va falloir
attendre deux semaines après la deuxième
dose dans le meilleur des cas
l'espacement entre les deux entre les
deux et trois semaines donc quelqu'un
qui aurait rendez vous demain et au vu
de l'affluence sur boqueteaux livre ce
soir je pense que c'est compliqué
pourrait avoir un test un passeport
sanitaire prêt pour la rentrée donc pour
l'automne
tout juste alors dans le chat vous vous
êtes nombreux à vous indigner donc de
cette obligation vaccinale déguisé avec
ce pass sanitaire obligatoire un peu
partout finalement happy days nous dit
si on nous traitait pas constamment
comme des veaux peut-être que le peuple
aurait un tant soit peu confiance en ses
dirigeants
en réalité cette situation est bien du
fait de macron ericsson qui nous rejoint
ericsson qui nous dit bonsoir j'ai raté
la locution bonsoir à vous le passé ni
terre sera obligatoire pour les hôpitaux
et les magasins alimentaires
c'est donc une question avec un point
d'interrogation les hôpitaux louis et
magasins alimentaires
ça reste total six heures voilà ça reste
à préciser ça dépend de leur dimension
il a parlé des complexes aux commerciaux
des centres commerciaux effectivement je
vois notamment une tonalité donc dans le
chat qui commença à grimper une tonalité
un peu vindicatif donc emmanuel marié
qui nous dit faut se rebeller et faire
pire que les gilet jaune et justine
alice je suis heureuse de lire tous vos
commentaires de rebellions et je suis de
tout coeur avec vous pour montrer notre
colère contre toutes ces normes
judith waintraub est-ce que vous pensez
que ces mesures vont être accepté par la
population
je pense que ce qui se manifeste le plus
sont le plus contre la vaccination
j'ai remarqué qu'ils compris parmi les
gens pas encore vaccinés et qu'il
n'avait pas
l'intention de le faire prochainement
quand on leur demande ce qu'ils feront
quand la vaccination sera obligatoire il
dit
je me ferai vacciner il ya quand même
une partie de légalistes à mon avis le
problème est plutôt inverse
est ce qu'on peut se permettre
d'attendre pour vacciner tout le monde
étant donné que comme l'a dit emmanuel
macron c'est une course de vitesse donc
de toute façon il ya une proportion de
jean vincent disait 25 % de gens qui
refusent de se faire vacciner les gens
qui travaillent les instituts qui
travaille sur les amphis de mimizan
ti'vac ce 10
c'est autour de 10 les vrais gentils
vague c'est une toute petite francs -10
15% oui donc cela de toute façon il ya
un risque qu'on ne les convainquent
jamais tant pis pour eux tant pis pour
eux quand ce sera obligatoire partout
mais mettre tout une société sous cloche
parce qu'une infime minorité refuse la
moindre contrainte pour se protéger
protéger nos systèmes de notre système
de santé et protéger les autres c'est
pas possible
alors ça continue beaucoup beaucoup on
va pas pouvoir continuer indéfiniment
avec vous ça fait déjà maintenant 45
minutes que nous des mairies font les
annonces des manuels macron jeu vous
pourrez retrouvez donc tout le détail
des annonces sur lefigaro.fr avec des
papiers récap nini 2020-2021 qui nous
rejoint instant et qui nous dit je n'ai
pas suivi le vaccin est-il devenu
obligatoire pour les personnels
soignants et bien oui à partir de j'ai
oublié la date de vincent bordeneuve si
vous vous souvenez l'obligation pour les
soignants ces structures c'est pour tout
l'été 7,8 mais il se sera déroulée le 15
septembre les solutions ne commence que
le 15 septembre
oui les airs ou c
oui c'est ça et pourquoi est il laisse
jusqu'au 15 septembre c'est parce qu'il
faut quasiment deux mois pour avoir le
parc ou alors il n'a pas précisé si les
sanctions auraient lieu si elle est une
seule dose
je pense qu'à ça paraît très incongru
mais c'est pour laisser autant de
prendre rendez-vous et l'obligation et
les deviendra effective elle est
effective dès demain il y aura un
contrôle et donc une véritable
obligation dé 15 septembre c'est
paradoxal parce que des premiers ou de
le 1er août pour le pour le coup il y
aura obligation montré un passeport
sanitaires pour l'ensemble des lieux
puis 52 secondes personnel donc là
l'ambition c'est quand même pu accélérer
cet été là les injections les injections
quotidiennes et d'éviter d'éviter à tout
prix un rebond dépit d'une lente
merci beaucoup vincent barnaud nav je
rappelle pour tous les internautes qui
vous ont suivi qui ont suivi aux
explications êtes journaliste
scientifique donc au service sciences et
métiers du figaro on retrouve au papier
dans le figaro et puis sur lefigaro.fr
quand avoue judith waintraub vous êtes
journaliste au service politique du
figaro magazine
on vous retrouve donc dans sur le figaro
enfin sur figaro.fr et également dans
les pages du figaro magazine
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
pendant ces 45 minutes
à très vite sur figaro live vous étiez
vraiment vraiment nombreux je peux pas
tous vous saluer en tout cas je vous
salue ce que je vois sur lefigaro.fr si
changer de bord chris kraus et tech
hatib lama et il ya qu'à faut qu'on qui
est là depuis maintenant longtemps avec
nous merci à vous tous pour vos
commentaires vos réactions à très vite
sur figaro live